i'm happy to see you all
so mr president welcome to the
washington dc va medical center we're so
excited to have you
not just visit this medical center but
visit veterans
in your term and see our vaccination
effort
i do want to introduce some members of
the team uh
dr deepika duganini
is a clinical pharmacist here on our
staff and she has been working about six
days a week sometimes seven days a week
uh since uh middle of december
that drawing up vaccine and leading our
team that does that
here we have lieutenant colonel sharon
tatiana
army retired army nurse corps officer
who is receiving her second dose of
pfizer today her vaccinator is dr
dr nikki corria our deputy chief of
staff but nikki has also really
headed our testing capability here
running a respiratory evaluation center
that allows us to
test both veterans and our staff and
veterans who are coming here for
pre-procedure testing
they have surgery done wonderful job uh
here receiving his first dose of the
new j vaccine of staff sergeant marvin
cornish
united states army george how are you
well sir
and the vaccinator is denise bain denise
is our associate director for patient
care services our nurse executive
but more importantly in in this
environment
denise has been the department of
veterans affairs representative to
operation warp speed
since november working to make sure that
va's across the country get the
allocation that they need
to take care of their veteran population
we're really warping the speed now
and then lastly colonel retired margaret
cope united states air force is
receiving her second dose of the pfizer
vaccine today
her vaccinator is dr leslie rowan who
has been our vaccine coordinator
here at the washington dcva
responsible for nearly 28 000 doses of
vaccine going into the arms of our staff
our veterans and 5 000 of our partners
at the department of homeland security
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so sir what we'd like to do now in the
explain
how we mix up and draw the pfizer
vaccine and
and how long before the guidance came
out to get sick get six doses out of the
bottle
uh deepika and her team were getting six
different about
liquid and we dilute it with 1.8 ml of
sodium chloride
and then we draw into syringes like this
0.3 ml each
and then we uh we note everything down
here and if anything's missing like five
or six dose
we have to refer to cdc and so we
maintain this vlog
[Music]
excuse me one second where is uh
jeff stein okay maybe he snuck in
i want you all to meet jeff science jeff
is the guy
who had the dubious distinction of my
asking to put together the entire team
and uh jeff is uh he also
handle uh along with some others ebola
in
our last administration but i just
wanted to see jeff
jeff's the guy doing a lot of the work
thank you your leadership with an
unbelievable team thank you
all right
so i start every day at 4 am
so i'll be ready with as many doses as i
can by
sometimes 6 30 and sometimes 8 a.m so
i practiced a lot earlier
you know 4 a.m
so i'll take it before i draw and then
so i have to point the
sodium
camera
hey
[Music]
there you go
hmm
i played with bubbles all day
now you prepare all these uh i have
um i have another i have
other people helping me so depending
upon the volume for the day
we plan and we are sometimes two people
sometimes
we went up to five people uh one day we
did like twelve hundred doses
so um four other people
so we have a team of it's between two
and
most days it's three to four that are
drawing up for example today we have
uh 537 vaccines scheduled across the day
uh that's a good day's work for three
pharmacists yes
yeah and how did you handle the weekend
with a thousand
uh when we do a thousand to twelve
hundred we have four to five pharmacists
that that are working
from about six in the morning till about
3 30 in the afternoon drama
vaccine the day we did 1200 we actually
pull in two extra pharmacists because we
had more people vaccinating than we had
we normally have about 25 vaccinators
when we're
doing a weekend clinic the day we had
1200 we had 38 vaccinators so we were
going through vaccine a lot faster
than the pharmacists were used to
so the first few hours will be really
quick
because there are always so many
vaccinators
more vaccinators than the people who are
drawing so we have to compete with them
so we so far we did we are doing great
we're doing pretty good across the
country here yes yes
we're uh we're going to reach uh
100 million doses pretty soon
but we have to focus more on getting
certain neighborhoods that are
at risk neighborhoods i think that's
where johnson
can help yeah we uh
boss could speak more to it but we uh
when we spoke with johnson and johnson
there was a little difficulty with
energy
to produce it so uh this guy got a hold
of mark and put them together
and did something that's unusual these
days put together
two competitors to help save lives
and they're kind of doing it and the
same
with uh with regard to
a couple of others that needed some help
in terms of
lacking equipment for their
manufacturers we were able to get that
done
so i learned from running the recovery
hack you got to be hands on you got to
get down to the detail
because it really matters you have to i
think
you've got to put together a hell of a
team and
so we still have to you know
i think to have efficiency you know we
have to have equity as well
making sure neighborhoods are covered
but you're covering the gambit here
it's impressive
i take my coat off except i've had my
tools
as soon as she finishes drawing them up
and labeling them we'll give them to the
vaccinators yeah
um denise do you have a j one therefore
i do
so this one oh wow
the inaugural yes that's the first one
here yes one here
all right you get one man i'm sorry did
i tell you what
no i'm
here in iraq he said i think hey you
feel a great officer now pal he's not a
dead i have no illusion
who runs family master sergeants they
run the army
all you colonels now you get that
straight i know
it's important she labels them because
four of those doses are going to go down
to our vaccination clinic and
into arms of uh one of those i think we
have 388 second doses scheduled today
so um
thank you thank you thank you thank you
now is this your first or second second
second and then i logged in
uh
[Music]
fire away so then we verify we
make sure that every person gets to see
what the vaccine
what it's labeled and then we verified
all their information we put the
information on their card for them
we circle it here and then we'll take
this back to the computers and put it
into the computer
electronic reference system
and so once we enter into the electronic
medical record and leslie signs the
the data automatically gets transferred
to the centers for disease control so
that they're able to count it
right away yeah remember to take a
picture of your card
don't land it and put it in a blank
um
nice to meet you thank you
thank you guys
let's go guys thank you thank you
oh
[Music]
uh
thank you sir you're welcome sir sorry
about that kick i didn't see it
my mixer's in the way and there was no
room to move